I was less fun it's much less fun
because we're in the post empire world
now I mean the up book publishing
flourished in the Empire you know and I
i can at look I haven't done any kind of
touring or any sort of book stuff for
about six years and even in these past
six years I can see a massive difference
in terms of how how it works I mean my
facebook and twitter stuff or personal i
mean i have my my twitter i have a
twitter account and i have a facebook
account that are solely mine and then
there's like three or four or five
others that are there primarily to
promote this new book and to get the
word out there that i am semi hands on
semi but a lot of other people are
dealing with those sites and maintaining
them and i'm completely for it I am I
had to like fight my publisher to you
know make sure that they were using
these networks in order to like promote
the book and they came around I mean
literally they will I don't think I
publisher was even using Twitter five or
six months ago I mean and then I was
having a fit about it and said you have
to use Twitter for you know contests and
information and all this stuff and and
they came around they started to do it
but um in terms of myself getting a lot
of satisfaction or enjoyment from it I
mean sure I mean I guess so on a certain
level but I'm also old you know compared
to you know the average you know a
person who uses those sites extensively
I have friends who are in their early in
mid 20s and the way they use facebook is
completely different from the way I use
mine you know updating your status
hourly and having eight different chats
going on at once and it being almost
second nature I mean to me it's kind of
amusing and a game and but it's not
something that I feel the need to
express myself with
you